he was once the world's most famous male
model even his looks were household
names
leti Gras Magnum and of course blue
steel but that was a long
I'm with Interpol I need your help she's
hot I trust her
what made you want to get involved with
with zealander were you big fan of the
first film yeah I was a big fan
absolutely I saw the first one more than
five times I had no idea they were
planning this equal and then Ben called
me and and told me that that he was
writing this with me in mine and I was
very surprised that they were gonna put
a copy when I do it and also that they
wanted me to be in it because I haven't
done a lot of comedy in English so I
felt this is very exciting very
surprising yeah I've read it and
immediately I called him back and I love
the character because he's she seems
like the more normal at the beginning
the normal one of the group but she's
also a little bit of a weirdo I see this
yeah exactly what do you think the film
says about fashion obviously it's a
parody and it's a comedy but what do you
think it says well the fashion industry
it would I know kind of well because of
my job yeah because of my designing
collaborations with different brands and
different friends that I have that are
designers or people that worked in
magazines I feel like I know it well and
I have also a lot of respect for it and
a lot of admiration for many of those
people for their talent for how hard
they work it moves a lot you know like
there are so many people in the world
that live from that industry and the
thing is that it also has this other
side you know yeah it makes it very easy
to find humor we have to yeah I think
it's really great that they
heavyweights of the fashion industry
will consider you know like they did
they are part of the film and it's a way
to give their blessing you know somebody
like now winter is in the film and she
even has a scene with dialogue yeah I
was really really happy to see you know
that that she that she has that sense of
humor yeah yes definitely
what do you think with the most accurate
parts of thoughts that they portray of
fashion well the in the movie yeah yeah
I think all the just the extreme
obsession with you know with the way you
look and thin or fat or this or that or
it also it makes so much sense to make
this movie now because from the first
one the world has changed so much yes
like how social media and internet and
the effect of that how that has affected
Hansel and erik no it's a metaphor of
what's going on like what the the scene
when Justin Bieber is almost dying and
the last second of his life he would
dedicate to find a filter for the
Instagram yeah but the last photo ever
so of course it makes you think in a way
it makes you laugh in a way at this for
me it makes me a little bit scared of
where are you I'm one of those people
that misses the the ritual of writing a
letter you know everything is indexed
everything feels cold and I'm one of
those people that have the hope that you
know both things can coexist yeah
absolutely people will watch movies in
their homes but they will also continue
to value the ritual of going to a movie
theater you can send that text but you
can also write a letter yeah having both
worlds
read a book touch the paper smell the
paper yeah all of these things for me
this movie makes me
about all of that importance it's not
about yeah and can you do a blue steel
not very well no Ben is the expert yes
he didn't give you any lessons in
teaching and I saw it every day for
months and months yeah twelve hours a
day that's the face I saw I'm what was
the funniest thing to film so many so
many and they took us to all these
amazing locations in Rome being at
Caracalla baths
yeah those tunnels in the middle of the
night which at one point I felt a bit
claustrophobic because I felt okay we
lose power if we get now in the dark and
we don't know which way to get out
because it's really like a labyrinth in
there but to be able to see all these
amazing places that nobody can't see
anymore because they don't even do a
tour anymore yeah so it was I love Rome
so to be there for three months doing
this
there's only one criminal mastermind who
could be behind all this prison chase me
I am bad to the core now
talked where's my goddamn latte